i'm joined now by the shadow health
secretary we're streeting a very happy
new year to you good to see you this
morning thanks for being with us all a
bit worrying this christmas and new year
uh over and as we head into 2022 some
really worrying statistics about just
how many of us are going to be unable to
get into work because we're sick with
covid the sunday times saying up to one
in 10 staff sick in the nhs the male
actually saying one in 40 but whatever
the numbers are
it's a concern what's the answer
it is a concern and happy new year i
think the key challenge for the
government at this moment in time is to
get testing right because if we've got
sufficient testing in place that's a key
tool in
managing the risk of the virus managing
the spread of the virus keeping pupils
learning as the school term starts
keeping nhs staff
safe and other workers in critical
national infrastructure safe
and avoiding the need for further
restrictions particularly in england so
that's the big message for the
government today i am concerned that
we've had shortages of tests the health
secretary told me only three weeks ago
that the availability of tests wasn't a
problem clearly it is
and if we get testing right we can avoid
the need for further restrictions so
that's the big message for the
government today
yeah the government's saying it's
tripling the supply of lateral flow
tests to 300 million
by the end of the month but of course
that is still some way off so you say no
more restrictions what about masks in
secondary schools then um kids going to
have to wear them in the classroom now
well i think in terms of schools if the
choice is between
having masters at schools or children
missing schools in huge numbers
of course we want to keep pupils
learning that's got to be the priority i
think there are two things though that
the government can and should be doing
the first is on testing people should be
testing twice a week there's lots of
evidence to suggest that hasn't been
happening properly so the message for
government is get the tests in place
make sure pupils are able to test twice
a week and my message to parents and
pupils is do take the test because the
big challenge this month is going to be
keeping pupils learning avoiding mass
absences and of course making sure that
staff are well enough to attend school
as well so the testing is crucial the
other thing of course is ventilation
ventilation is a really big tool
in preventing the spread of this virus
it's an airborne virus we've urged the
government to act on testing repeat on
ventilation repeatedly they've made an
announcement today that they're going to
send out 7 000 air purifiers to schools
across the country i mean that's only
one in four schools across england so
nowhere near enough and i'm not clear
from what the government said whether
this is one system per school or one air
purifier per school because there's a
big difference between the two
and again i'm afraid it looks a little
bit like a rushed last minute
announcement to give the appearance of
doing something on a big issue where
they should have taken action a lot
sooner so i think the government's got a
lot more to do on ventilation in schools
as well as a key defense a key
mitigation against the virus
we're in this strange situation at the
moment aren't we where we don't yet know
what the effect of us all being able to
mix at christmas that intergenerational
mixing over christmas and the new year
we don't know what effect that is going
to have on the numbers yet we probably
won't know for a couple of weeks and on
the one hand you've got sajid javid and
indeed labour saying that more
restrictions are absolutely the last
resort but on the other hand you've got
the bma saying the nhs is already
overwhelmed it's in a parlour state and
we need restrictions now um who's right
well we're listening very closely to
what
some of the country's leading scientific
minds are saying i've had lots of
meetings in recent days between
christmas and the new year to get a
sense of of what their view is i'm
listening very closely to what nhs
leaders are saying i mean in the end
this is the key challenge for the
country it's to make sure that the nhs
isn't overwhelmed that it's there for us
when we need it and that's not just
about covid that's about the big
pressures we normally see on the nhs at
this time of year it's also about
critical national infrastructure so i
want to reassure people about a couple
of things first is that in the event
that new measures are needed labor will
do the right thing we're not going to
play party politics on votes we showed
that before christmas
the second is we are urging government
to do everything they can to avoid the
need for further restrictions i think
testing is a really crucial tool in all
of this which is why i'm concerned about
the testing shortages
because in the end i would labor fix
that because we know it's an issue how
would labour have done things
differently than with testing because
we've all been testing like crazy we've
been doing what we were told taking
tests before we meet granny uh or go to
the pub um and uh obviously um
there's a supply issue but how would
labour solve that
what were two things firstly
people have been doing the right thing
you're absolutely right and it shouldn't
have been a surprise to the government
that there's been high demand for
testing because they've encouraged it
and in fact we we introduced as part of
the plan b measures
the covered pass scheme where people can
produce negative tests in order to
access nightclubs and larger venues so
we are actively using testing so we
challenged the government to make sure
there were sufficient tests in place and
were told only three weeks ago that was
the case clearly it isn't and that's not
good enough so there is a question here
about basic competence from the
government of course we are where we are
this isn't where we would have started
as the labour party but we are where we
are and so if prior if if we have a
shortage of tests and priorities have to
be made our priorities are keeping
pupils learning so prioritizing schools
prioritizing nhs staff and critical
national infrastructure that that's got
to be the priority for now but the
government does need to get its act
together on the supply of testing and i
think the health secretary needs to
explain
why it was that only three weeks ago he
told me in the house of commons that
availability of tests wasn't a problem
and yet now it so clearly is
perhaps it was because uh there was this
messaging that more restrictions weren't
going to be brought in but
we all needed to be cautious and it does
appear that we we have listened to that
we have been more cautious and we have
done things uh sensibly and just before
we let you go um
what are your thoughts for the next few
weeks the next few months um the data
does seem to be a little bit confusing
in many ways and you can understand why
people are confused at the moment
because on the one hand we have these
huge number of cases you know well over
150 000 cases
a day and yet on the other hand deaths
thankfully uh don't seem to be
increasing dramatically and also the
number of people on uh ventilators in
icu also seems to be steady and
plateauing um it's very hard for people
as we enter into the new year to know
exactly where we're going
yeah and i think it's important that
politicians whether in government or
opposition
aren't complacent about the need to
continually explain to the public what's
going on what numbers we're watching and
why so that people can understand the
decisions we're taking so on on that
note i would just say to people that the
key challenges we've got to keep an eye
on this month in particular are nhs
staff numbers and there's a sunday times
article suggesting 10 of nhs workers
were knocked out on new year's eve
because that the numbers of staff in the
nhs is going to have a big impact on
their availability to deliver the
service this is a people-based service
ultimately so we've got to keep an eye
on nhs staff numbers we've got to
prioritize schools and making sure that
children can keep on learning and the
third thing we need to keep an eye on is
there are some signs from the data that
there's now an uptick in the numbers of
older people who are now getting the
omicron variant so care homes are going
to be a pressure this month as well so
so all in all the things that we can put
in the positive column is that so far
there are signs that this variant isn't
as harmful as previous variants the
reason we can't be complacent about that
and this is in the challenging column
is the the virus is spreading rapidly it
is knocking out lots of staff in the nhs
and other critical national
infrastructure it is going to be a
challenge for schools this month it is
going to be a challenge for care homes
so the big challenge for 2022 because
the virus isn't going away the big
challenge for 2022 is how we put in
place the infrastructure
to make sure that we can live well with
covid without having to go in and out of
lockdowns or other restrictions like the
hokey cokey i understand why people are
tired of that so that means testing i
think in particular
really good tool
and getting the vaccine roll out
continuing so if you haven't had your
first second or booster jab do it now it
really is the best tool the best defense
we have against this virus okay we're
out of time we appreciate you being with
us this morning we're streeting shadow
health secretary thank you